ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung
heute geht es um die politische
Philosophie von jür habbermaß wir haben
uns schon mal kurz mit ihm befasst in
der Übersicht der historischen Übersicht
über zentrale Position der politischen
Philosophie ich mach oben rechts den
Link hinein heute soll es ganz kurz und
pränant um sein Hauptwerk gehen um seine
Theorie des kommunikativen Handelns
diese Sendung reicht lange nicht aus um
alles genug zu besprechen wir wollen uns
konzentrieren auf ein paar zentrale
Begriffe ein paar zentrale Zitate um so
ein ganz kurzen Einblick in seine
Theorie zu
erhalten wichtig ist sie natürlich das
kommunikative ver handeln was bedeutet
das das bedeutet dass man handelt also
interagiert in einer Gesellschaft inem
man kommuniziert Kommunikation ist
nichts bloß äußerliches was keine große
B utung hat für Jürgen habberm ist die
Kommunikation das Band was die
Gesellschaft genauer genommen die
demokratische Gesellschaft Demokratie
zusammenhält das heißt Kommunikation
muss nach bestimmten Regeln erfolgen
diese Regeln werden wir uns gleich ein
bisschen genauer anschauen wenn es
nämlich um seine Theorie des Diskurses
geht der Diskurs ist eben eine Form von
Kommunikation die nach bestimmten Regeln
verläuft die sich dann am Ende als dem
tisch zeigen wir lesen hier mal ein
zentrales Zitat er sagt hier folgendes
wo er auf den Diskurs zu sprechen kommt
er sagt der Diskurs lässt sich als
diejenige erfahrungsfreie und
handlungsentlastende Form der
Kommunikation D verstehen deren Struktur
sicherstellt dass teilnehmen Themen und
Beiträge nicht beschränkt werden also es
gibt die Freiheit die neg Freiheit
Freiheit von Beschränkung dass kein
Zwang außerdem des besseren Argumentes
ausgeüt wird ja also negative Freiheit
ganz wichtig Freiheit von von Zwang von
Beschränkung und was ist der einzige
Zwang der Zwang der die Regeln des
Diskurses angibt das ist das bessere
Argument also Diskurs heißt noch habmals
nicht sagen zu können was man will
deswegen kritisiert auch habermaß die
neuen Medien die sozialen Plattformen
weil hier kein wirklicher Diskurs mehr
zustande kommt weil hier gar nicht mehr
wirkliche Kriterien für das bessere
Argument entwickelt oder auch
kontrolliert werden so zumindest seine
These also nur das bessere Argument die
besten Gründe sind hier ausschlaggeben
natürlich sieht man hier da wird ein
sehr hohes
rationalitätsideal vorausgesetzt und man
kann sich natürlich fragen ob ob die
Kommunikation immer so rational ist
nicht vielleicht auch irrationale Formen
immer eine Rolle spielen und vielleicht
sogar auch spielen müssen das eine
weitere Frage die wir nicht hier
diskutieren können er sagt weiter dass
infolge dessen alle Motive außerdem der
koperativen Wahrheit suchen
ausgeschlossen sind also es kommt nur
darauf an gemeinsam durch den Zwang des
besseren Argumentes Rationalität die
Wahrheit zu finden wenn unter diesen
Bedingung über die Empfehlung eine Norm
anzunehmen argumentativ das heißt
aufgrund von hypothetisch
vorgeschlagenen Alternativen reichen
Rechtfertigungen Rechtfertigung sind
Begründungen ein Konsensus also ein
Einverständnis und gemeinschaftliches
Einverständnis zustande kommt dann
drückt dieser Konsensus einen
vernünftigen Willen aus wir sehen hier
gibt es eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit zum
gemeinwille bei rousau der wie wir
gesehen hatten auch eine Form von
rationaler idealwille ist ich ma oben
rechts den Link zur Sendung über
Rousseau hinein die Frage wie sich
haberm zu Rousseau verhält ist eine
spannende Frage man kann sich also
fragen ob habbermas nicht doch am Ende
ein kontraktualist ist also einer der
sagt politisch stabile Strukturen kommen
durch Verträge zustande so ist es aber
nicht nach habmaß ist der Diskurs die
kommunikative Hand lung kein
kontraktualistisches Verfahren sondern
ein Verfahren der Argumentation und
nicht der Vertragsschließung wir sehen
das gleich noch Anh von anderen Zitaten
er entwickelt hier ein alternatives
Demokratiemodell ein drittes neben dem
republikanischen Modell und dem
liberalistischen Modell und davon grenzt
es ab also Liberalismus sagt jetzt
habberm ist zu sehr auf das Individuum
konzentriert und seine Freiheiten die
häufig auch so eine Art von Freiheit des
Marktes sind das der
Konkurrenz teilweise kommt ja auch
instrumentelle Vernunft ins Spiel die
uns nur als Mittel zum Zweck gebraucht
er ist aber dann auch nicht gleich das
Gegenteil nämlich ein kommunitarist
mache ich oben rechts den Link rein zu
dieser Sendung wo wir uns damit befasst
hatten Kommunitarismus auch davon grenzt
er sich ab weil er sich vom republikanis
abgrenzt Republikanismus macht eben die
Gemeinschaft stärker und fast die
Gemeinschaft als etwas auf was
Stabilität besitzt und nicht so sehr die
Prozesse analysiert die zu dieser
stabilen Gemeinschaft hinführen aberms
geht es aber gerade um die Prozesse die
zur stabilen Gemeinschaft führen
angesichts der individu und die
miteinander auch argumentieren so und es
geht ihm eben jetzt jenseits von
Liberalismus und Republikanismus um ein
Demokratiemodell welches sich an den
Kommunikationsbedingungen orientiert wir
sprichtte jetzt von der Diskurstheorie
die nimmt Elemente beider Seiten auch
von Liberalismus und Republikanismus und
integriert sie im Begriff einer idealen
Prozedur für Beratung und
Beschlussfassung das hatten wir schon
gesehen das war der Diskurs die Zwänge
des besseren Argumentes das ist seine
Form von Rationalität spricht einem
demokratischen Verfahren also ein
Prozess was zwischen zuen stattfindet
und dieses Verfahren besteht in
Verhandlungen selbstverständigungs und
gerechtigkeitsdiskursen ja er möchte
also eine praktische Vernunft entwickeln
eine praktische Rationalität die es mit
Diskursregeln und argumentationsformen
zu Tonung und die nicht so sehr bezogen
ist auf universale Menschenrechte die da
so abstrakt existieren wie es vielleicht
der Liberalismus tut und auch nicht auf
die konkrete Sittlichkeit bestimm
Gemeinschaft wie es vielleicht der
Republikanismus tut od der
Kommunitarismus s er möchte gemßen
zwischen beiden vermitteln möchte
dasjenige betrachten was dazu führt dass
überhaupt Menschenrechte gegründet
werden können oder dass es zu einer
Gemeinschaft kommt einer stabilen und
das sind eben die argumentationsformen
die er in den Blick nimmt ja also die
ideale Prozedur man sieht das ist
ziemlich idealistisch man kann sich
natürlich fragen ob das überhaupt auch
noch realistisch ist ob wir wirklich
immer so diskutieren und auch
diskutieren sollten woder diese Regeln
kommen ob sich dieser Diskurs wirklich
immer so entwickelt ob sich überhaupt
mal dorthin entwickeln wird das ist die
Frage die man natürlich an ihn stellen
muss wir haben noch ein Zitat
wo er jetzt hier noch mal auf die
Diskurstheorie zu sprechen kommt er was
die als ein Prozess also Demokratie ist
nichts was einfach so erzeugt werden
kann s Demokratie muss immer wieder
durch
kommunikationsverhältnisse garantiert
und geleistet werden hergestellt werden
wir sind da sehr verpflichtet um
Demokratie aufrecht zu halalten das ist
nichts was einfach so stabil existiert s
das entsteht erst dann wenn wir
rationale
kommunikationsverhältnisse eingehen die
dem Zwang des besseren arguments
gehorchen das ist hier sein seine
Theorie und
er grenzt sich in seiner Theorie auch
noch von einer Auffassung des Staates
als einem zielorientiert handelnden
Subjekt ab was kann man sich darunter
genauer vorstellen z.B den lebiata bei
Thomas hbes der hatte ja davon These
vertreten dass wir individuelle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger alle unsere
Rechte Freiheiten delegieren müssen
abgeben müssen an den Staat der dann ein
großes Subjekt wird und nur so sagt der
HS können überhaupt uns Freiheit
vorstellen und man sieht hier sehr
deutlich hier wird der Staat
personifiziert hier werden dem Staat
personale Eigenschaft zugesprochen der
Staat wird wie ein handelndes Subjekt
gefasst und das möchte habms nicht HABM
sagt Subjekte sind immer diejenigen
Subjekte der Kommunikation
er möchte sich hier auch von einem
bewusstseinsphilosophischen Modell des
Staates abgrenen so als eben als ob der
Staat mentale Eigenschaften hätte ein
Ziel verfolgen würde das sagt er sind
immer die einzeln Mitglieder der
demokratischen Gesellschaft die eben das
durch die
selbstbestimmungspraxis herstellen
müssen ja das ist nicht das große
staatssubjekt s sind die individuellen
Subjekte
die miteinander kommunizieren müssen auf
eine rationale Weise nur so sagt jetzt
hab können wir wirklich eine stabile
Demokratie erzeugen
das war es in aller Kürze ich bedanke
mich für die Aufmerksamkeit bis zu einer
nächsten Sendung